the police killings of George Floyd in
Minneapolis and Rashard Brooks in
Atlanta have shaken up millions of
people but no one feels the impact more
than the two women in their lives
Rashard Brooks Widow that's Tameka
Miller and George Floyd's partner that's
Roxie Washington we invited them to
speak with us together they talked to
exclusively with mark Strassmann about
their loss and the legacy of both men
good morning to you mark I'm thinking
they must have had a whole lot to say to
each other no question Gail and here's
why both women belong to a club that no
one wants to be a member of and the
reason is the initiation fee it is
unthinkable black man dies violently in
this country his relatives grieve and no
one understands their stab of pain like
another family was gone through the same
thing
Roxie Washington and Tameka Miller had
never met but they relate to each
other's anguish like best friends
Washington's partner was George Floyd on
May 25th he died on a Minneapolis street
a cop's knee pressed on his neck for
more than eight minutes 18 days later
and Atlanta cops suspected Rashad Brooks
of DUI when Brooks ran officer Garrett
Rolfe shot him in the back
Brooks was Tameka Miller's husband the
father of their four children pretty mom
I'm stealing disbelief we take it day by
day hardest part it's the questions my
daughter like can't she go to Haven when
is she gonna be able to again the two of
you was it like to meet for the first
time when I saw you and the baby I was
like I gotta get there like millions of
people
Miller watched George Floyd I did you in
raesha talked about it we actually did
my husband was in disbelief he was
heartbroken he actually cried it must
have been surreal when
it came back millions also watch the
shooting of Rashad Brooks including Roxy
Washington when I saw it I was like not
again not again
neither will watch the video of the man
in her life dying but both were
fascinated by the protests that followed
it made me feel good to know that his
name will be remembered but someone they
had never met before loved what did the
protests mean to you that it brought all
different colors and races together I
mean so much to me
six-year-old Gianna is the daughter of
George Floyd and Roxy Washington she
said it changed the world none like we
was going somewhere and she saying
I believe that there are some good cops
and there are the bait cups one officer
involved in each death was charged with
murder Derek Chauvin sits behind bars
for Floyd's death awaiting trial but
Garrett Rolf is free after posting a
$500,000 bond then came to this moment
Washington slid over to comfort Miller
she understood
Derek Chauvin has yet to enter a plea
his representatives did not respond to
our request for comment Garrett Rawls
lawyers intend to fight the charges they
argue that his shooting was justified
why because Brooks fired a Taser a
trough both women we spoke to of course
want justice to Washington justice is
for both officers to spend the rest of
their lives behind bars but Miller told
me at this point she doesn't know what
justice is Gail a lot of people are
asking that question mark there was a
very tender moment between the two of
them because we were all saying not
again not again when we saw the death of
Rashard Brooks I get the sense did you
get the sense of being in the room with
them that it must have helped them beau
to be able to talk to each other cuz
they are certainly as you said in a club
nobody wants to be on two now I bet
they're bonded for life to talk to each
other and to commiserate with with many
of the challenges since the shooting
I'll give you an example something that
touched me as a parent
both women having to explain what
happened to their young children take
little Gianna her mother tried to make
sure that John and never saw the video
of her father dying on television but
someone accidentally left the channel
the wrong channel on little girls son
and all of a sudden Gianna had more
questions mmm-hmm
I keep thinking about those young
children too and Gianna's words my daddy
changed the world I don't even know if
she knows what she's saying what it
really means but she's right he really
did change the world I think about those
young kids thank you Mark